cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com
let's talk about the story from NBC News
YouTube suspends Russell Brand from
making money off his channel the BBC
also pulled some of the British Stars
shows from its streaming services
following rape and sexual assault
allegations against comedian which I
might add are 20 to 10 to 20 years old
he's developed into a wellness and
conspiracy influencer this is
I mean this is it right here this is the
hammer in the nail the final the final
nail you've got people the media is
saying all these people are conspiracy
theorists for thinking there's an agenda
against Russell Brand okay you want to
make the argument that the BBC Channel 4
these networks were like look we don't
know whatever it is you're involved with
Russell Brand so we're gonna take your
shows down it's our Network it's our
Channel we're taking your shows down
it's like okay that's shady YouTube
suspending monetization from Russell
Brand's Channel makes literally no sense
they didn't suspend his content they
didn't ban his channel they just
disabled ads from his channel and his
channel doesn't break any of the
advertiser rules so for what reason did
YouTube take his money away this just
reeks and this is an another uh I mean
this is it
this says outright the likelihood here
is that there is an agenda to or
deperson Russell Brand oh there's no
there's no question and once again we're
now living in a world that is we are
guilty before being proven innocent when
it used to be the other way around
people can say anything about anybody
now and they're going back what I heard
17 years on him right now then where was
this person 17 years ago why are we
waiting so long to hear what these
people are saying and why do they have
any uh what they have any room to stand
on when they wait that long it's
ridiculous it's crazy to hear these
stories because it's like what evidence
does anybody have 20 years later I I
think I say well look what they did
Kavanaugh right you know I'm trying to
put them on the Supreme Court
there's already the text messages the
wonky looking text message that's very
clearly doctored uh from Russell Brand
that's the lines don't add up the texts
are in different shades is all sorts of
uh not exactly you don't buy it right
you're like did you did you look at that
did you look at okay so there's a
there's a text message uh in which he
apologizes to the woman and if you look
at it it's it's missing time stamps the
text half the text isn't bold half the
text is not uh it doesn't align on the
left and the right it's off angle it
doesn't say iMessage rather than text
message uh there's all sorts of problems
with it but it goes beyond that now
right we're past uh yesterday was about
guilt or innocence and in in me two
cases you just don't know like at the
end of the day you're gonna have to take
your uh on what side do you fall and
then say look look I'm never gonna know
the answer to this it's going to be he
said she said so what do you do now we
have to ask the question it's no longer
about guilt or innocence that will be
decided uh in the court of public
opinion now now it's looking like the
the government is looking into possibly
charging them who knows now it's about
what are the what's the Fallout is the
timing suspicious the timing is
absolutely suspicious he has six million
followers six million subscribers on
YouTube and he speaks out a lot against
Tim you mentioned Ukraine and War or
he's also very much in uh against big
Pharma and in election cycles that are
decided by a few hundred thousand votes
a guy with six million subscribers who
reaches a lot of people has a lot of
pulls so when people say like it sounds
conspiratorial that they would try to
take this guy obviously no it doesn't
like do I buy it no I don't know for
sure but I know that the government
especially our government has done a lot
worse for a lot less well so here's the
issue with your text message thing at
this point all of the media Outlets that
are covering the story have already
created their own Graphics of those
texts so you can't I I can't look I
can't find what you're talking there's
something about this text that someone
pointed out a lawyer I think it was uh
and we can look at this text and read
through this Texas you want the last
thing she writes to him is that she
Prides herself uh she used the wrong
word but on being safe and trying to
make the right decisions obviously this
was a bad one so she's acknowledging
that she made the decision to do what
she did which a lawyer said that that
kind of indicates that it wasn't rape
but it's be but it's beyond the language
it's about the fact that it looks
doctored if there's a but even that way
they're not even talking about anything
specific yeah for all we know he could
be talking about he he had her he was
screaming and ranting about how he was
going to eat 27 milkshakes and then he
had to apologize her because he was like
oh I'm so sorry I behaved that winch
like you freaked me out last night that
was inappropriate she got a rape kit
this girl the next day that same day
yeah she went to a Rape Crisis Center
um she had a kit done she did not choose
to press charges back then now they're
saying that all of the women that have
come forward one actually is named um it
escapes so out of five women one
actually gave her name uh and they talk
a lot in the in the segment they're
talking about The Bravery of these women
I said the woman who who gave her name
is is Brave the woman who actually comes
forward and puts herself in the public
eye is Brave the rest of this is like
look we still live in a country that
operates under the premise of Innocence
until proven guilty but they don't need
to do that anymore especially with
figures who go against uh the narrative
that they want to push they can kill you
in the court of public opinion they can
well you gotta wonder if they'd be doing
this if he he was on the other side
politically yeah
clearly not okay of course no question
Mike Tyson I know a lot of people like
Mike Tyson he actually he has an actual
rape conviction he is not demonetized on
YouTube Colleen Ballinger who is uh who
is a kids YouTuber who has very very
serious grooming allegations against her
is not demonetized on YouTube there's
all sorts of Youtubers with very very
serious claims made about made against
them that haven't had their channels
demonetized because that shouldn't get
you demonetized it has to be something
that is done in a court of law and it's
third party it's off app Behavior
anyways like they don't really have a
leg to stand on Luke pointed out cardi B
didn't she admit to raping guys no she
she drugged it she drugged and robbed
men who paid her for sex oh okay okay uh
and then a lot of people have a hard
time with that one because they're like
look these guys are suckers they set
themselves up for them like that doesn't
matter there was still something done
against them it's like the party B was a
hooker yes uh she was a stripper in a
yes the lady of the night we'll say that
uh and there's just in an industry in an
industry that loves to promote horrible
Behavior here's another thing there's a
there's a show this was a chance
everything about Russell Brand is coming
out on Channel 4 right now there's a
show called naked education on Channel 4
that runs right now in which adults
stand naked in front of children so that
they can help destigmatize different
body types am I supposed to buy that
channel 4 who runs that show is the
Bastion of good Consciousness I don't
think so and it's uh it's insane uh you
don't nobody deserves to be lectured by
these scumbags well this is like January
6th it's all selective attacks they just
decide who they want to choose and when
they want to choose and if they're
hurting us we're going to take them down
when they say us you're talking about
government you're talking about Pharma
companies you're talking about whatever
it may be that is going to be against
the agenda of what the left wants and
when you mention hypocrisy it's exactly
right they don't care if they're
hypocritical no that doesn't matter
there's no truth but Power there's a
great video and I'm sure you've seen
this it's got to be like three four
years ago when Nancy Pelosi's up in
front of the press and say we create a
smear and we tell you about at the press
and then you take it and you make it
real for us have you seen this video
it's unbelievable she oh it's like four
years ago it's up there you can find it
she openly admits that they'll lie and
let the Press you guys our favorite left
wing press you guys will go out there
and make this person's life miserable
it's a presumption of innocence yeah
it's really a center piece of what
allows us to exist as a society is
acknowledging that we're all innocent
until we can somehow get a group of
peers together to to find proof
otherwise but
um that doesn't mean that corporations
don't have immense power and control
over your finances we'll end with cases
like this it plays on our you know our
imminent desire to protect other people
right so it's very very hard to come out
and say to someone like look I can't
take your word for it on something like
this and this was what happened look
there is also it's to your point uh
Danny Masterson who was just convicted
there was no benefit of the doubt given
to him because he's part of the
mainstream and he's uh he's a
Scientologist so he has that working
against him so people are saying you
know lock him up throw away the key with
something like that now we have Russell
Brand and you have to wonder why is he
being targeted the Danny Masterson is
different this is this case it's like
the uh they don't really seem to care
who they go after in these cases and
people get caught in the middle but I
think for brand it's absolutely
politically at least now with the like I
was on the fence yesterday with the
YouTube demonetization his show is
getting canceled now all his uh
stand-ups have been put on indefinite
hold his book deal has been put on
indefinite hold it feels extremely
coordinated
agreed
seriously it's just it's it's what we're
doing in this country right now and
going after people for no reason
whatsoever and uh they they it's a power
trip it's a power gain this country's
socialist now and they want to keep
working down that wrong road I think the
funny thing about this is you know when
you when you look at the store and the
allegations made against Russell Brand
it's like okay you know all right let's
let's let's say these accusations are
correct whatever uh they didn't care
at all back then because he was on their
team
and now that his anti-establishment
anti-war it's like what do we got 20
years ago fire away huh well look how
long it took the Harvey Weinstein right
yeah they protected they all know it
Oprah was protect them all kinds of
people and that was going on Seth
MacFarlane made jokes about it and I
think it was Courtney Love Too right
Courtney Love said don't no she she
wasn't making jokes she was asking she's
like don't go don't go into a hotel room
with Harvey wines right they all knew
yeah they all knew they did nothing why
because it's beneficial for him a lot of
these women knowingly went with him too
knowing that they were like this is a
path to power and fame there have also
been like there have been women that are
coming out and saying like I've had no
bad experiences with Russell Brandon
then people are like well what does that
matter because these accusations say he
doesn't like exactly that does not hold
any more weight than that in this in
this case outside of the fact that you
can't prove in a court of law that any
of this happened what is a general
person supposed to do in this other than
say I don't know maybe maybe not and
YouTube should not I I one I think I
think Russell Brand should sue Google
for uh like breach of contract or
something people need people people need
to understand that uh the agreements
that you have when you sign up for one
of these Services is a mutual contract
they tend to be of course obviously very
favorable to the corporation because not
like you get a red line and send it back
or anything like that but
Russell Brand's got a monetary deal with
YouTube he produces they run ads they
split they split the money in a certain
percentage if YouTube is going to
arbitrarily shut his channel down when
he broke no rules I think he I I I'm not
a lawyer but I think that there is a uh
a claim here because YouTube is going to
have to justify in court that for no
reason at all or actually this is
different they these contracts always
say we can terminate your account for no
reason and there's questions in certain
States or wherever the United States
whether or not that matters especially
when YouTube is now saying they
suspended Russell Brand because of the
allegations yeah when they said offline
Behavior now they've given a reason now
Russell Brand can cite that reason as a
potential violation of the contract and
this has been going on Beyond just
YouTube I mean patreon has been doing
this to people for years uh kicking them
off the platform because of off you know
off-brand behavior and stuff on the
platform platform Behavior but also like
not just that but like we had videos so
Me Andy senior had videos that were all
demonetized or at least limited ad
Revenue just talking about it and there
was nothing in the language in any of
our titles nothing in any of our
thumbnails that would have triggered
anything like that and that's a problem
when they're clearly if you look up
anything to do with Russell Brand now on
YouTube now maybe it's different now but
for as of four hours ago before we went
live I I saw you covered it this morning
right and that by the time we went live
your video had 88 000 views at that time
right and the nearest one that I saw in
the top five to six search results on
YouTube was about forty four thousand I
think that was from the USA Today or
something like that but that was from
yesterday now every single one on the
entire first page of search results were
all what they call authoritative news
sources so you're only getting one side
of the story anyways my video on the
Russell Brand Story got as of this
morning 300 so it got 310 000 views and
I'm just talking about your demonetized
one I'm just talking about the one from
this morning no I'm saying talking about
his demons right right that one had more
views than the highest viewed of any of
the mainstream news sources on that
first page nowhere to be seen because
they want to be able to control who sees
what and who gets what information for
people who are listening uh and I'll
tell you I think if YouTube had their
way this show would not exist but they
but the thing that YouTube does is
suppression and removal from the
algorithm and the problem that they're
facing is people choose to watch this
show knowingly which means for a lot of
people who produce content
it's the front page recommendation where
people will find the content and that's
true for a lot of the clips we produce
on this show and the clips we produce
viewership is lower than it used to be
because they have been suppressing us
and we get a lot of people who message
us saying like your the live show didn't
appear today I had to type it in and
find it and I'm like that's right but
it's really hard so they they they they
try to be careful because
they don't want to do outright no reason
bans of big content because it creates a
PR storm and potential legal issues so
they go for the suppression route and
hope that you eventually Fade Into
Obscurity and then cease to exist sure
but if that's what Facebook did to me
right but if people watching this show
share the URL
and then through text messages through
acts through whatever YouTube can remove
it from the front page or sometimes
people tell us they'll go to youtube.com
timcastirl and it doesn't even appear on
the channel page like we will have
people who say it's not even on the live
do you ever contact them and say what
are you guys doing why is that they say
oops Yeah whoops oh yeah Whoopsie Daisy
well that's Hollywood Creative
Accounting as well you're right you'll
find their their you know if you make a
back-end deal in Hollywood that means
you're pretty much gonna take it in the
back end because everything they can not
to pay you yeah and it is they even
coined the term uh Creative Accounting
yeah if you listen to anybody in these
Studios they're going to say any show
didn't make any money they're just gonna
say until you come after them Disney
movies movies are all bankrupt oh
they're they wouldn't make any money but
we just keep making movies out of the
goodness of our heart but it's just
amazing but for YouTube to take him down
and stop and stop him from making money
and to me already says oh he's guilty
and this is what's going on right now
we're saying people are guilty before
they do it and Hollywood's gonna keep
doing that I love them when Ricky
Gervais got up what is it was it was it
the golden than globes he hosted like
four years in a row yeah he even said to
Hollywood he goes he goes if the Taliban
had a film fund you'd be the first
people you know to sign up yep because
because that's what they do he uh also I
guess it is fair to point out that he's
not he's not banned from YouTube he's
just demonetized which is just to
disincentivize him from using it but
hopefully Rumble didn't get something
demonetizing reduces your viewership in
the algorithm so this has long been the
case I don't know I I can't speak to
what YouTube's algorithm is definitively
I don't know but it has long been the
case that many of the research
scientists who use YouTube and a lot of
these there are a lot of people who like
try and track and figure out how YouTube
works if you are not running ads in your
content YouTube is less likely to show
your content duh YouTube's gonna be like
hey if you don't put ads in your content
we don't make money from it it costs us
money so we're not going to show it yeah
so if they demonetize brand they're
likely going to stop showing his videos
in the recommended feed or whatever but
like they were for the most part anyway
and this is the issue with the with a
potential agenda against Russell Brand
he's too famous he's got what does he
have 12 million followers or whatever on
X yeah he's got six million on YouTube
and he's anti-ukraine War
a lot of people think they're going
after Russell Brand because of the covid
video where he talks about big Pharma
and I'm like ah look man you go after a
big Corporation they smear you you go
after the government by saying no war in
Ukraine and the intelligence agencies
has uh what did what was it Biden who
said this who said this was a Schumer
they got six waves from Sunday to deal
with people like you or something like
that sounds like a Schumer thing yeah
they're talking about Trump so you know
I I'd imagine this has more to do with
the fact that a high profile celebrity
is generating massive opposition to
their war effort in Ukraine and right in
time for the election next year it's
interesting isn't it one year out
remember
they got rid of Alex Jones and apologize
Watson and Milo and Laura we were that's
the crazy thing right we were like when
we were talking about this earlier we
were getting everything ready I'm like
who are the people that were banned like
I remember everybody remembers Alex
Jones and it's like this is the point we
couldn't remember him I couldn't
remember Paul Joseph Watson a guy Laura
couldn't like didn't come to my mind
because if they get you out of the
algorithm if they to get you off the
platforms you're essentially
non-existent now people will forget that
you exist because you're not being seen
on a daily basis I wonder if I wonder
how much time we got left you know here
at uh Tim cast IRL because I mean come
on in 2020 we were getting like a
million plus hits per night and I think
that probably made us one of the biggest
podcasts in the world I mean I mean
during the election cycle specifically
in these like two months I think we had
something like 180 million uh views per
month some ridiculous number now it's
like 60. so it's like still really good
really good and as we're entering 2024
it's likely that we're going to get
massive viewership again because we are
the like you know for whatever reason
people like you guys listening you like
watching the show I I imagine that
they're gonna look they got they go with
the biggest voices well they're watching
you that's for sure absolutely suddenly
a bunch of abused chickens are just
going to come out of the woodwork and
we're gonna have to deal with
allegations in the company I don't know
I think it'll just be like what they do
with Crowder right so what there's
nothing to come out against Crowders
like always getting divorced they try
and smear them over that stuff and it's
like you can't there's nothing really
there than some some personal issues but
so what they do is they they give them a
strike from 15 uh from a video 15 months
ago and then oh now you can't stream for
a week and they're just basically
erasing his content very very slowly if
they were to ban Crowder outright they'd
make a huge Splash which would cause PR
problems Death By A Thousand Cuts
exactly yeah slowly slowly over time
they will seek to remove people I think
that that may be considered a human
rights violation in the future for for a
corporation to strip you of your bank
account access or for a company to strip
you of your monetization I think it
should be considered human rights
violation right now but I imagine that
the direction we are going in this
culture war is that they're going to
keep doing it and it won't be a
violation that it could lead towards
that and then there's some sort of
devolvement and dissolution of the human
species and then we have a third world
war and then From the Ashes we create
something where we're like we cannot
make that mistake again it might yes or
it might go the route that we integrate
a digital Human Rights bill thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time